America's Got Talent the champions
kicked off in a major way delivering
powerful performances and even a tearful
golden buzzer moment very happy very
humble thank you over 12 years after
Bianca Ryan won the very first season of
a GT she returned to the stage to show
off her pipes but first she shared her
story I finally went to an ENT
he was like basically one of your vocal
cords it's paralyzed and there is a
chance that you may never be able to
sing again now at 24 Bianca says she's
working hard to make a comeback
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
fan-favorite susan boyle made a
triumphant return to the stage that made
her famous she reflected on her success
and shared her powerful message I've
sold over 20 million records even for
those who maybe don't have the
confidence to do things for those who
maybe don't have a voice but ones who
people tend to ignore I feel I'm a
champion for them
[Applause]
[Music]
no surprise here Susan had the audience
and judges clapping on their feet but
this was the icing on the cake I want to
be the woman that gives you something
that you deserve
everybody Susan Boyle alleged
[Music]